Oh where is excited about what
capabilities and project fugu whoa right
awesome so my name is Tom and I'm a
developer advocate at the web team at
Google and I see the web as the
universal development platform and when
I describe my role I tend to say my job
is to enable developers to do anything
they want to do on the web they want to
do on anything they do on the web and I
expect them to do on native and I'm Pete
I'm also a developer advocate on the web
team I love my job because I kind of
look at it as I get to take all of the
sharp edges off new web tech and make it
easier for you to use now I'll admit I
am a little bit biased I kind of love
the web I think the web is the best
platform out there what I love is this
scale right it reaches users all around
the world essentially on any device it's
easy to use and easy to share there's
nothing to install it just works but
most importantly it's an open ecosystem
that anyone can use or build on almost
everything I do today I do on the web
I've got a tab open to Gmail and
calendar and drive I do all my code
reviews in github I'm write all of my
samples and stuff to make your lives a
little bit easier on a glitch to try and
just it sold on the web it's kind of
awesome and in the last couple of years
the capabilities of the web have grown
tremendously with things like web USB
camera controls media recording and so
much more but let's be honest the web
does have some limitations and there are
some apps that are just not possible to
build on the web today if you want to
build something that interacts with
local files on the user system nope
can't do it want to do something that
interacts with the users contacts on
their on their phone sorry
nope want to register as a share target
so you can receive shares
sad panda and as cute as it is it's
still a sad panda
right we call this the app gap the gap
between what's possible on the web today
and what's possible on native and on the
chrome team we want to change that gap
we think web apps should be able to do
anything that native apps can we want to
remove yeah who was that who yeah all
right we want to remove those
limitations and so that you can build
and deliver apps that were never
possible before on the open web
without requiring some kind of framework
or anything like that just straight on
the open web we've been working to close
this gap for some time now and with
things like the web app manifest which
makes it easier to create an installed
experience with service workers that
allow you to get that performance and
reliability that users expect from an
installed experience web assembly that
gets you closer to the metal and so much
more but some of these features that
we're going to talk about over the next
40 minutes or so seem a little scary at
first especially when you consider how
they're implemented on native but the
web is inherently safer than native
opening a web page should never be scary
right adding these new features needs to
be done in a way that respects user
privacy trust security and the core
tenants of the web our internal code
name for this project kind of alludes to
that project fugu fugu is a type of fish
that when it's cut properly is
considered a delicacy and if you've ever
gotten to try it it is pretty delicious
but it's also poisonous you cut that
sucker the wrong way and you're dead
like that's that's it we look at these
features it's the same way we need to do
them in a way that is absolutely right
so nothing should ever be granted access
by default instead they should rely on a
perm
model that puts the user in control
right and is easily revocable it needs
to be crystal clear when all of these
api's are being used and how they're
being used we've got a good white paper
there that dives deeper into some of our
thinking around this so you can check
that out now obviously there's a ton
more I could talk I could talk this
whole session about the security model
for all these things but that's not all
that exciting so every one of these
api's needs to be done in a way that
balances the needs of you the developer
with the needs of keeping our users and
their data safe users should never be
put at risk simply by going to a webpage
now we've identified about 75 features
that we think are critical to closing
that app gap and I'm sure there are
probably many more you can see the stuff
that world currently looking at by going
to see our bug comm and looking for bugs
that are tagged proj fugu now guiding a
feature from sort of that idea to a
standard standard I've shipped API is
important to us and I showed this quote
earlier but I want to show it again
because I think it's really important as
we work on these it's really important
that we maintain the core tenets of the
web that means that we're designing
these and building them as web standards
everything I'm going to talk about is a
web standard and I'm really kind of
psyched about the fact that other
browser vendors are getting involved in
this Microsoft is actively working on
several new features including app icon
shortcuts and Intel implemented the
generic censors API and they're
currently working on wakelock and web
NFC so how do we do this
well the first step is we identify a
need all right
specific use case now many of these are
things that you've told us about either
by talking to us directly or by filing a
future request on CR bug comm as we
start to think about the API we put our
initial thinking into an explainer
essentially a design doc that is meant
to explain the problem
and show some sample code about how we
think this problem is gonna get solved
once the explainer has a reasonable
level of clarity it's time to publicize
it and start to solicit feedback from
you so that we can iterate on the design
we need to hear from you to make sure
that the use cases are actually covered
properly is there anything that we're
missing or like did we maybe just
completely it Biff up the the whole API
implementation and during this time as
we get feedback from you
we keep iterating on that explainer to
get it better and better but we're also
looking for public support at this point
to get public support from you can be as
simple as a tweet from an engineer
saying hey that's really cool
we'd use that in our app if it were
available your public support a helps us
to prioritize the API so we know how
many people are gonna use it and how
important it is to you but it also tells
other browser vendors how important it
is to you so they can go Oh lots of
people want that maybe we should do that
right so once the explainers in a good
state we transition from the explainer
to the spec alright and where we
continue to work with developers to get
your feedback and other browser vendors
to keep iterating on it as the design
starts to stabilize we typically use an
origin trial to experiment with the
implementation origin trials allow us to
try new features with real users and get
feedback on that implementation this
real-world feedback helps us shape and
validate the design before it becomes a
standard finally once the origin trial
is complete the specs been finalized and
all the other launch steps are completed
it's time to ship it so enough
background I've talked too long let's
look at some real stuff Tom you want to
do the first one
sure all right Thank You Pete so
Bluetooth Low Energy or just ble is a
very less technology that you can find
in many gadgets like Hardware sensors
beacons lights and also toys
but many times you know want when you
want to interact with a ble device they
make you download yet another app and
actually you should just be able to use
a web app my Bluetooth can be used to
control all sorts of devices after
pairing them which is painless and quick
and works by a picker for example the
Batmobile from Lego can be controlled
from a web app without a need to
download and 85 we actually have the web
more view other with the Batmobile not
the Batmobile the Batmobile over in the
web sandbox over there so please come
over and play with it before connecting
to a web Bluetooth device like the
Batmobile I first need to know its ID
the Bluetooth service UUID that you can
see here is unique identifier that lego
gave to the Batmobile
I can optionally also provide a name or
a name prefix parameter you can think of
these services filter as a way to not
only look for certain devices but also
for certain categories of devices for
example to just look for hybrid sensors
or just for devices whose name starts
with hub which is the name that Lego
gave to the Bluetooth controller inside
of the battle view when and then request
a device I will see it in the connection
picker where I can then pair it and
start using it web Bluetooth is a very
powerful API so it requires a secure
connection and the connection picker
only shows after you suggester after the
pairing step I can then connect to the
device's server that provides the
services of the device in a concrete
case a Batmobile remote control service
how cool is that web Bluetooth is an
established standard that has been in
chrome for a while it's fully shipped
and you can use it today if you have a
great use case I have built a cool demo
like Nields with the Batmobile control
app that we've showed the sandbox do let
us know awesome sharing is a critical
feature for many apps and it means
whatever that means let me try that
again sharing it's really critical
whether that means you're sharing out or
you want to be able to receive shares
many native apps can plug into the
system sharing api's and the web should
be able to do this too with the web
share api you can it allows yours
site to share links and text via the
system share picker working with the
share picker it's pretty straightforward
it's best huge feature detection because
it's only available on some devices
right like your Windows or Mac OS device
doesn't have a share so you want to fall
back to the whatever the [ __ ] native
sharing mechanism is but if it is you
just provide the text title and the URL
that you want to share and then call
navigator share and that's it it's
pretty easy we just also added I think
this one is pretty cool the ability to
share files as well so you can share not
only links but you can share files the
other side of the equation is the
ability to tell the system that you are
a share target that you want to receive
shares from other apps and the web share
target API allows an installed web app
to register with the OS as a share
target so that users can easily share
apps to you or share links and text to
you in fact Twitter just recently
implemented this if you've installed
Twitter you can try sharing and see hey
I want to share a link over to Twitter's
install that to register as a share
target you need to add the share target
entry to your web app manifest and when
the user chooses to share to your site
it opens a link to the actions page that
I've got link there and sends over the
required information so for Twitter what
they do is they just compose a new tweet
with the information that you provide
just one pro tip here if you're gonna do
this make sure you pre cache your share
target page so that it loads instantly
and works reliably otherwise if you do
it and it's like not loading users are
gonna get a little cranky and they're
not gonna use it
so web share and web share target are
available today and they provide a nice
way to integrate with the system but
we've also been working on web share
target v2 which allows you to receive
files you can now send files but you can
also receive files and so I suspect that
that'll probably land a little bit later
this year around chrome 76 or so so on
your computer your laptop or your
desktop computer often
you have media keys that you can use for
playing or pausing your media content of
as giving a favor to backward for web
apps these keys typically are not
accessible but there's actually no
reason why they shouldn't be accessible
when you build a media player app you
could for quite a while now use androids
media controls in the control panel via
the media session API and not only use
rich album artwork but also obviously
use the media controls to skip forward
and backward pause play and so on what's
new is that now you can finally also use
media keys on physical hardware keyboard
to control playing pausing skipping and
so on of your media and this also works
where the media tab is in the background
or in full-screen mode to make this
happen a set of action handlers in the
navigated media session interface for
the previous track action yeah you can
applaud for that it's really cool it's a
great API so you set up action handlers
in the media session interface for the
previous record action for the next
record ssin for play and for pause the
media session idea is fully shipped now
and it works on Android Mac OS Windows
and Chrome OS and support for Linux is
under development suite alright with
getusermedia getting a video stream from
the users web cams pretty easy and you
can use javascript libraries to do face
detection or you can do QR codes and
that kind of thing in fact a couple
years ago in the chrome experiment movie
Conti Revo that's how it worked you
navigated by moving your head to move
through the experience but doing shape
detection in JavaScript is kind of
expensive and most native platforms have
api's for this built-in so the shape
detection API is something that is about
to land and it's got three interfaces a
face detector a barcode detector and a
text detector the face detector does
exactly that it can find a face but it's
just finding your face there's no facial
recognition there and sometimes it can
find landmarks so like it could find
your eyes your nose in your mouth so you
could use that for maybe taking a
picture when everybody's looking at the
camera or imagine trying on a Paris on
classes or glasses before you even try
them in your hand and you guys all look
better you all look better when I have
my glasses on so that's a good thing um
the barcode detector does exactly that
right it can scan all kinds of barcodes
and Tom's gonna dive into that a little
deeper in a minute but the text detector
what do you think it does it finds texts
now each detector has a detect method
which takes an image or a video or a
blob it'll check that image and
asynchronously return whatever it finds
we just finished an origin trial with
the shape detection API and one of the
key reasons that we do an origin trial
is it allows us to validate the design
in this case we realized that there were
some things that we needed to change and
make some update so we're updating the
spec a little bit and making some of the
methods a little bit simpler we also
realized that text detection wasn't at a
level that we were happy with so we
probably won't ship that one for a
little while until we get the quality
level up so as you can see and Pete's
demos there's some really need use cases
for the shape detection API but pulling
all of that together so that will work
across browsers is a bit tricky the
shape detection API is coming out of an
origin trial but not all mobile browsers
supported yet but fortunately this is a
really good example of where JavaScript
library can help and make life easier
for you using platform IDs were
available and javascript and web
assembly where they aren't we're happy
today to announce an early version of
the perception toolkit a library that
allows people to navigate your site with
a camera this idea of navigating your
website by pointing the camera at
physical things in the world has a lot
of power actually and it can help users
complete tasks faster and easier for
example if you want to learn more about
a product sometimes instead of typing in
a search box it can be way easier and
very faster to just scan its barcode to
find the page that you're looking for
another use case is museum tours where
rather than forcing your visitors to
download yet another app that they will
never use again after the museum visit
you can just scan the actual artworks
from the web
and just deliver directly a rich
enriched online experience the
perception toolkit does planar images
action which means which museums have
digitized there are bugs already it is a
really small step for them to make these
artworks recognized by the toolkit the
perception toolkit does three things
first
it manages a camera session for you and
can detect barcodes QR codes and 2d
image targets using 95s when available
and as I said earlier web assembly when
not next it allows you to link real
world targets like barcodes with pages
on your website and this is done using
structured data so it's easy to manage
and finally it makes the user interface
really easy from unwinding the user to
rendering cards you have full control
over the user interface but it takes
care of the heavy lifting the whole
thing is open-source
so there's a lot of flexibility to
customize how everyone of it but the
general idea is that you can get up and
running really quickly to add camera
based navigation to your site if you
want to try this out we have a live demo
over in the web sandbox you can do this
on your own device so just go to the URL
that you can see on the screens and yeah
once you are in the website the website
works area try pointing the camera at
physical things science logos and so on
and see what's coming up suite installed
apps can frequently alert users about
new information either through
notifications or through a badge on the
icon badging makes it really easy to
subtly notify the user that something
might require their attention or it can
indicate a small amount of information
badges are less intrusive than
notifications and they don't interrupt
the user which means that they can be
updated much more frequently and because
they don't interrupt the user they don't
require any special permissions to use
them there plenty of great use cases for
badges chat and the email could indicate
progress games could let users know it's
their turn and plenty more just one
small thing about them they only work
when the app is installed right because
if it's not installed there's nothing
for us to badge
so setting the badge is pretty easy call
window dot badge set it takes an
optional number if you provide that
number it uses that number if you don't
provide a number it just sets it with a
dot and then you can clear it with with
clear it's available as an origin trial
right now on Windows and Mac and we're
working on Chrome OS support so you can
start using it today
during the origin trial though you'll
need to call window dot experimental
badge set if everything goes smoothly
this should be available and stable
around chrome 78 we're still looking for
signs of public support for this so if
this is something you think you might
use please tweet us or let us know
because this is a pretty cool one and
we're getting close and want to want to
see some use on that yeah all right
boo-boo so the last clock had four
rounds of applause I think we're at four
so like let's keep going this is good oh
crap oh my screen just went off Oh
luckily it's back so a lot of devices
can keep yeah the screen on when they're
running for example a presentation app
like PowerPoint can prevent a screen
from falling asleep from turning off
luckily we can sort of do the same
pretty soon again on the web as well
because presentation apps like Google
slides have very much the same use cases
so why shouldn't they be able to request
something that is called a wake lock
that prevents from happening what just
happened so to avoid joining the battery
most devices can quickly yeah go to
sleep and turn a screen off and they're
idle this is fine most of the time but
some applications do need to keep the
screen on or prevent the device from
sleeping so that they can continue doing
the work
I mentioned keeping a screen awake
during presentations but there plenty
out of really good use cases for example
a run tracking app turns the screen off
but it needs to keep tracking where you
are to record you out or maybe a game
where you focus on the screen while
thinking about the next turn and you
don't want the screen to turn off when
you think about your next turn the
wakelock API enables you to
support use cases like that and new
experiences that until now required a
native application the API also aims to
reduce the need for hacky and
potentially power-hungry burke rhoads
like looking an invisible video that
people use nowadays to keep the screen
on the backlog api provides two types of
egg lock screen and system a screen my
clock prevents the device from turning a
screen off so that the user can see the
information that's displayed on the
screen and a system backlog prevents the
device's CPU from entering the standby
mode so that your app country can
continue running and while they are
treated independently one may imply the
effects of the other for example a
screen backlog implies that the app and
therefore this system should continue
running in order to use the backlog api
and integrate and initialize a wakelock
object for the type of wakelock i want
here i am requesting a screen wake lock
once created the promise results with a
break lock object but note the way clock
isn't active yet until you can before
you can use it you need to activate it
before activating the wake lock let me
first set up an inventor listener so
that i can receive notifications when
the wakelock state is changed to
activate the oaxaca i need to great
create a request and now finally the
screen won't turn off ever again
until of course I cancel the right job
you probably have noticed the red ribbon
in the upper right corner this means
that the spec is currently being
rewritten based on early feedback and
the code that you can see here will
change but what you can see here is also
what you can actually play with today
way clock is moving along really well
the folks at Intel have been busy with
yeah rewriting the implementation and
it's available behind a flag but again
please note that the current
implementation will change I suspect
we'll start something in an origin trial
probably around chrome 76 maybe 77 but
it could change yeah depending on how we
make progress with the API and so forth
sweet
all right so apps that read and write
local files are essentially impossible
to do on the web today right you need to
like upload some
thing if you want to start working on it
you need to download it and put it back
in the Downloads folder or save it back
it just doesn't work very well the
native file system API aims to change
that making it possible for users to be
able to give to choose files or
directories that a web app can interact
with on the native file system single
file
editors like squoosh which is a PWA our
team built earlier this year are an
ideal use case for this control o to
open a file compress it ctrl s to save
it and then just repeat and of course
there are plenty of other office
examples notepad for editing text
Sketchup for doing drawings figma for
doing prototypes all that kind of thing
beyond single file editors we also want
to enable the ability to work with
collections of files so think like photo
photo galleries or media players and the
one that I'm most excited about
personally I dream of the day when vs
code just works as a progressive web app
and I just use it straight in my browser
that will be pretty amazing the one key
design element of the API is that its
primary entry point is a file picker
that will require a user gesture to
invoke this ensures that the user is in
full control over what the web app has
access to and we expect that some files
and folders web apps just won't have
access to at all as I said earlier users
should never be scared about visiting a
website or web app we're still iterating
on the spec for this so this code might
change but grab the file I want to open
get the file read it into an array
buffer make any changes I want then to
save it get a file writer and save it to
disk there's an early draft of the spec
in the works but there's no code that
you can try right now so this is still
one of these ones that's a little bit
future-looking as with our other stuff
if you think this is cool and want to
get involved please go check out some of
these links thank you Peter
so many devices such as microcontrollers
or 3d printers communicate through
serial data up until now these devices
can't be integrated with Web Apps but
what if they were a way to bridge the
physical and the web worlds by allowing
them to communicate together even though
modern pcs rarely include the classic
nine pin serial port a lot of the device
is driven by microcontrollers such as
robots and 3d printers communicate using
serial data but nowadays commonly over
USB or maybe Bluetooth so let's have a
look at how the serial API will work in
profit practice first I need to filter
for no vendor IDs in order to request a
port to the device in question here I'm
filtering on the Arduino USB vendor ID
remember it's all serial data so I need
to agree on a board rate when opening
the port that determines the
communication speed that is used with
the mint communicating over the channel
finally I can unreal arehd err until
there's no more data which the reader
signals with a damn flag the actual code
will look similar to what is defined in
the specification but somewhat at some
of the details so need to be worked out
the Beamish model will work similar to
that of web USB we started the web the
serie API maybe for the capabilities
project and before it's processes came
into life so some of the details do need
to be defined there's an implementation
behind a flag but most of the work has
been so far on getting the permission UI
right but I can request permission to
access as he report today the object
that your script gets back isn't
actually useful yet but we're aiming to
have proper support by end of the port
so there are a whole bunch of
peripherals that communicate with your
computer using head the most common
classes of hit devices are keyboards and
mice but there are a whole bunch of
devices that are not well supported by
the hit driver and are often
inaccessible to webpages web HID would
make these devices accessible and
provide better support for devices that
have limited functionality so many game
pads for example have decent support in
the browser but they frequently miss out
on some of the cool neat features that
they have with web hid the device
specific logic can be moved
into JavaScript so providing full
support and there are plenty of other
use cases extra buttons on like blue T
or thee on the colophony headsets could
easily control videoconferencing gaps
you could control virtual reality
experiences with spatial controllers and
just one note though like web hid isn't
intended to get high-level input where
we already may have a high level API
like key presses and pointer events
those are going to continue to be used
with the high level IP is this sample
opens up a head device grabs that first
matching device opens up a connection to
it sets up a listener to be like oh hey
you move the joystick and since hid is
bi-directional it sends out a report to
activate some of the lights on the
device letting the user know that the
device is ready to go there is a draft
of the spec available now so but there's
nothing to play with code wise so we'll
see that probably around chrome 78 or so
thank you this one's cool so access to
the user's context has been a feature of
native apps since almost the dawn of
time and it's one of the most common
feature requests that I hear from web
developers and this is often the key
reason why they still build a native
application getting access to the
contact there are many great use cases
for a contacts figure here on the web
but at the core it is designed to help
you reach your friends and family easier
for example in a web-based email client
the picker can be used to select the
recipients of an email or someone to
connect with on social networks but
instead of providing a site with
complete and continuous access to the
users contact the contact picker API is
just add an on-demand picker
when invoked it has a list of a user's
contacts and makes it easy for them to
pick only the contacts that they want to
share and users can provide access to as
few or as many of the contacts as they
choose and because access is on-demand
each subsequent call to the API will
show the picker again and designing the
API we want to give developers two
features that they want but we also want
to ensure
that their contacts and their own
information is safe and they clearly
understand what they are sharing that
means that the contact speaker will only
work when served from a secure host and
it can only be shown after user gesture
users can also explicitly choose which
contacts they want to share and see
exactly what is being shared before
their shared opening the contact speaker
starts with a call to navigator the
contacts dot select that I need to pass
an odds options object to with
information I'd like so here I just want
one contact and from this contact I want
the name the email and the telephone
numbers the corner turns a promise the
resource with an array of the corner
contacts that that were selected by the
user so let's say the user has selected
sundar Pichai why not each contact will
include an array of all the properties
that were requested for example our
address book entry for Sundra has his
name no phone numbers but it does have
an email address for him so go email
sender we're in the early phases of
experimentation with the contacts picker
API the explainer has been written and a
very first implementation is available
behind a flag but a lot of the details
still need to be discussed for example
whether they address whether where the
addresses should be accessible via the
API like the other IPS that we've talked
about we're looking for public support
so if this is something you think that
you could use in your website do let us
know all right well that didn't get a
round of applause
ok there we go yeah that one all right
so I'm going to cover this last one and
then we will wrap up real quick but
designers frequently have customs bonds
installed on their system that they use
for creating apps company standard fonts
specially licensed fonts that kind of
thing browsers can use them if they know
about them but there's no way to get a
list of those fonts the font access API
has two components first it allows apps
to enumerate the list of locally
installed fonts so that it's easy to use
them within your app and second it
allows access to the details of the font
such as the individual glyphs and
ligature tables so that web apps can
take fine-grained control
of rendering using things like half buzz
getting access is pretty simple so we
just called navigator fonts query and
give it up query parameter in this
particular case I've asked only for
local fonts I can then loop over the
list of fonts and add them to a font
selector we're still working on an early
draft of the explainer and we're looking
for feedback to make sure that we've got
all the use cases covered so take a look
at this and let us know especially if
this is something that you're really
interested in so as Pete said in the
last couple of years the capabilities of
the web have grown tremendously today
we've only covered a handful of the air
guys to be shipped but that we are
planning to ship later this year that
will all help close the app gap where
there are few other features that we're
working on that I want to at least
quickly call out we're adding support
for programmatically copying images to
the clipboard which is the most popular
bug and chrome spark tracker actually
more than thousand one hundred one
hundred thousand eight hundred stars
currently the asynchronous clipper dpi
only supports basic reading and writing
of text but we will be rounding out the
existing asynchronous clipboard API with
support for images again helping to
unlock a couple of really new creative
use cases then we have the SMS receiver
API that gives developers the ability to
be notified and specially formatted
formatted SMS messages are delivered to
the users device so that they can yeah
powers out OTP tokens for example this
can help reduce the friction when
verifying phone numbers and can be used
as a mechanism to limit abuse in account
creation it can ease account recovery or
it can being used to confirm critical
operations web developers have the
ability to display notifications using
the web push and notifications API
notification trigger is a mechanism for
preparing notifications that are to be
shown when certain conditions are met
for example the trigger could be
time-based it could be location-based or
something else this makes it possible to
display notifications at a particular
time without involving a server and
improves the reliability and
yeah improves the reliability by
removing the dependency on a network
connection this is essential for certain
types of applications like for example
calendars so while most of the API is
that we describe today aren't available
yet some like the web share and the web
chat target API already are available
and there are a few others that are in
origin trial that you can all start
experimenting with today I'll give you 2
3 seconds for taking pictures of that
slide all right cool
so if you want to participate in an
origin trial with your site the list of
the currently active origin trial can be
found at developers thought chrome
dot-com slash origin trials and finally
if there's any features that you think
we were missing like we mentioned like
75 but there might be more who knows we
want to hear about them
please file a feature request on bitly
slash new - fugu - request so after all
this we've just two links that you need
to remember the first is for the code
lab where you can experiment with other
ready to play with api's not everything
works on all platforms yet and sometimes
you may have to set a flag to use them
but as the admittedly biased author of
the code lab I do think it's a lot of
fun and the second link is for a
capabilities project landing page we
will keep it up to date and it is out
links to all the capabilities that we
work on and that are currently in flight
from there we also link to the full list
of all the upcoming capabilities that we
will get to in the future the web is an
amazing place and we're really working
hard to close that app gap so thank you
very much for being part of our journey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]